microfossils first discovered in
Australia in 1982 then thought to be
minerals have been re-examined with new
techniques showing carbon-based life
existing 3.5 billion years ago the
fossils which are just one-eighth the
width of a human hair could suggest the
common presence of life throughout the
universe and a baby in Tennessee was
just born after her embryo was
cryogenically frozen for 24 years which
is not only a record but it means the
baby was conceived only a year and a
half after her mother was born Vsauce
Kevin here this is mind blow
[Music]
researchers at Georgia Tech are using
ultrasound and machine learning to
develop a new way of controlling
prosthetic limbs
this approach created highly detailed
maps of muscle movements which enable
the fine control that most prosthetics
lack and it's so effective it's already
being referred to as Luke Skywalker's
Bionic hand you may remember from mind
blow 102 that Georgia Tech was also the
source for a robotic smart arm capable
of responding and adapting to a drummers
actions a rare form of blindness caused
by gene mutation could soon be treated
using gene therapy a trial in which a
virus was loaded with a normal copy of
the rpe65 gene and then injected into
the eye resulted in blind patients
navigating a specially designed obstacle
course more effectively researchers are
optimistic but they pointed out that the
treatment does not represent a cure
they're unsure how long the virus will
continue to express the normal rpe65
gene and although our price hasn't been
set one estimate puts it at a million
dollars but regardless of the challenges
the first gene therapy treatment
approved by the FDA is a major milestone
nanometer scale CT imagery has allowed
us to see the leg of a tiny newborn
velvet worm finally physicists at the
Technical University of Munich have
designed a machine using a new type of
x-ray tube capable of presenting 3d
scans of the smallest biological samples
that worms leg is four hundred millionth
survey millimeter this is so beautiful I
just wanted to share it with you so
they're okay that's enough electrical
stimulation of the amygdala can boost
your memory for a day at Emory
University Hospital deep brain
stimulation and ministered along with
specific images resulted in 79 percent
of subjects recalling those images the
next day with gains up to several
hundred percent meaning they've
remembered it better so maybe the next
generation of cramming for a test will
involve brains shocking your way
in a autonomous system labs map lab is
an advanced visual inertia mapping
framework capable of generating highly
accurate renderings of new and old
spaces basically it's a really advanced
quick way to map in 3d render locations
a sl's robot constructs a model of its
environment while a separate process
handles localization and multiple data
sets can be looped together to improve
accuracy
it seems to me potential future
applications of this could include
creating rich accurate virtual reality
experiences or to map tourist
destinations like the Louvre the iCub
humanoid robot is constructed to be like
a four-year-old child and now that it's
been around for more than 10 years it's
getting more sophisticated it can now
use stereo vision to estimate the pose
and strategy required to grasp unknown
objects with care which also enables
safe gentle interactions with humans
still no estimate for a c-3po level
sophisticated troy but they're working
on it
AI motives full-stack software suite is
poised to enable self-driving cars in
any weather or driving condition the AI
Drive Suite combines data from four
separate engines recognition location
motion and control to analyze and adjust
self-driving action in any situation so
instead of using lidar to scan the
surroundings they're using camera
sensors to feed data to software which
they say allows for higher resolution
information and analysis like
differentiating a child from an elderly
person and really the next steps are
making the system cheaper and more
energy efficient google's artificial
intelligence has discovered a planet it
used data from NASA's Kepler space
telescope to find Kepler 90i which
circles the Sun like Kepler 90 star
every fourteen point four days and it
was discovered using machine learning to
analyze changes in light readings that
happen when distant exoplanets pass in
front of a star Kepler 90 eyes surface
temperature is
about 800 degrees Fahrenheit so it's hot
the UK's National Physical Laboratory
has created the world's smallest
Christmas card at just 15 by 20
microliters it's 200 million times
smaller than a postage stamp when
magnified five thousand times you can
see a snowman and season's greetings
from NPL who used an ion beam to slice a
silicon nitride membrane coated with
platinum to carve the card with
incredible precision to absorb
mind-blowing knowledge through your ears
with amazing precision check out packing
for Mars by Mary Roach on audible I read
this book for my video the planet behind
your eyes and we also included it in
Curiosity box number two get a free
audiobook with a 30-day trial today by
signing up I've made it super easy for
you just text Vsauce 2 to 500 500 or go
to audible.com slash Vsauce - that's
text Vsauce 2 - 500 500 for audible.com
slash Vsauce - there's a link at the top
of this video's description for you to
click now I'm going to leave you with FX
- a giant human riding robot and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
mapmaking in the olden days was like
painting a masterpiece a slow laborious
and highly specialized task requiring
the utmost skill and patience mapmaking
today has the speed of our modern
streamlined methods but it is still a
highly specialized occupation the
biggest catch in making road maps is
keeping them up-to-date modern map
makers have solved this by developing a
trick method of printing revised maps
can be put out every two weeks as rule
these map detectives work in pairs one
man driving the car as the other plots
road changes on a special chart book
notations are carefully checked against
special instruments to ensure complete
accuracy when all this last-minute Road
information has been transposed to the
overlay sheet the sheet is removed and
placed in a special vacuum frame a huge
camera then photographs the overlay onto
a glass negative this negative is
photographically transferred onto a
sensitized zinc plate which after having
its face washed in an acid solution is
ready to be inked and locked on the
press this press swiftly over prints the
detour symbols onto the latest standard
road maps these in turn are
automatically cut and folded to the
proper size ready to give folks a good
steer
yes mapmaking has changed has kept pace
with a changing America modern maps
guidance over the modern road to the
land over great super highways such as
the famous new Pennsylvania Turnpike
modern Maps taking today's motorists
where they want to go when they want to
go quickly comfortably and Satan
[Music]